[Musique]
avec vous Hélène Frade bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline dans la presse
aujourd'hui le désaccord on vient d'en
parler entre l'Ukraine et ses alliés
occidentaux qui affirment que le missile
qui a explosé mardi en Pologne a
probablement été tiré par les forces de
défense
ukrainiennes soltenberg le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN assure que cette
attaque n'était pas je le cite une
attaque délibérée de la part de la
Russie tenue néanmoins responsable de
cet incident à cause de la guerre
qu'elle mène en Ukraine et cette
déclaration fait la une ce matin du
final qui montre les dirigeants de
l'OTAN réunis en marge du G7 réunion en
urgence le missile russe est
ukrainien c'est ce qu'elles vont ce
matin le quotidien italien il fête au
quotidien soulagée de voir je cite une
nouvelle guerre mondiale évitée et les
bellicistes de tout bord battre
finalement en retraite soulagement
également du quotidien suisse Le Temps
qui salue la retenue de l'OTAN et du
gouvernement polonais dont la réaction
aurait été je cite aux antipodes de
celle du président ukrainien celui-ci
vous l'avez dit à assurer n'avoir aucun
doute que ce missile n'était pas à
l'Ukraine et c'est une déclaration jugée
intempestive par le temps qui voit la
parole je cite toujours de vos le dix
meilleurs hélinski décrédibiliser des
avoués par Washington ce qui pourrait
selon lui peser lourdement sur les
relations futures entre l'Ukraine et les
États-Unis on ne termine pas les guerres
en les amplifiant mais en s'asseyant à
une table des négociations la tête
froide prévient le journal mais la
guerre est loin très loin d'être
terminée et le Wall Street Journal juge
lui que l'incident de mardi plaide
plutôt en faveur d'un renforcement du
soutien de l'OTAN à l'Ukraine notamment
via la fourniture de missiles seuls deux
longues portées que Kiev réclame depuis
longtemps et dont l'administration bidon
ne veut pas entendre parler jusqu'à pas
voulu entendre parler jusqu'à présent en
tout cas voilà pour ce dossier ukrainien
en Iran le pouvoir Hélène redouble de
violences contre les protestataires deux
mois après la mort de Marsa Amini
c'était le 16 septembre dernier à
Téhéran on a déjà 5 condamnations à mort
contre les soi-disant et Métiers près de
15000 iraniens détenus et plus de 326
personnes tuées dont 43 enfants selon
l'ONG Human Right Watch d'Iran cité par
le quotidien libanais L'Orient-Le Jour
le journal dénonce un recours à l'arme
de détention massive par le régime qui
emploie toute forme de toutes les formes
de répression possible dont ils
disposent des coupures d'Internet vous
avez forcés des méthodes que la diaspora
tente de contourner en particulier les
journalistes en exil qui deviennent de
ce fait des cibles à leur tour le
Washington pose quotidien américain fait
état Pauline de l'inquiétude des
services de renseignements occidentaux
face à la multiplication des men à
l'encontre des journalistes et des
dissidents exilés en particulier au
Royaume-Uni ou le chef du MI five
affirme que les agences de renseignement
iranienne sont prêtes à prendre des
mesures imprudent je le cite pour
attaquer des opposants dans les pays
occidentaux ou tenter de les attirer en
Iran une répression l'entend tous
azimuts qui n'affaiblit pas cependant la
lutte des Iraniens et des iraniennes
l'humanité a rencontré trois d'entre
elles actuellement exilés en France nous
ne nous Terrons plus promettent-elles
hommage également cette semaine du
magazine Paris Match qui salue
l'héroïsme des Iraniens avec cette photo
d'une manifestante prise à sa caisse
c'est au Kurdistan iranien là de là où
était originaire marsalini les
autoroutes les autorités par non
iraniennes Hélène qui redoutent que
l'équipe nationale de football n'affiche
à solidarité avec ce mouvement de
contestation
lors de la coupe du monde de foot au
Qatar qui commence dimanche c'est
indépendant Iran ou ailleurs rapporte
que l'entraîneur portugais de l'équipe
iranienne carlosch à cependant déclaré
que les joueurs étaient libres de
s'exprimer lors de la compétition et
c'est un message qui a visiblement reçu
cinq sur cinq l'attaquant sa manigodos
qui a dit hier qu'il était nécessaire
d'utiliser la compétition pour exiger
des changements en Iran je ne vais pas
je ne veux pas mélanger la politique
avec le football mais le football passe
au second plan en ce moment parce que
des gens perdent la vie en se battant
pour la liberté la coupe du monde de
foot au Qatar décidément devenu malgré
elle la tribune de la lutte en faveur
des droits de l'homme c'est avoir aussi
cette semaine avec ce numéro de Courrier
international sur l'effet boomerang de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar anémie reçoit
le ballon un ballon de foot en pleine
figure un effet donc involontaire de
cette Coupe du Monde quel international
on ne se quitte pas là dessus Hélène
avant de vous dire à tout à l'heure
Pauline je vous propose d'acheter
je vais y arriver ainsi à l'équipe qui
revient sur l'arrivée de Charles Caudry
en tête de la Route du Rhum
malheureusement en deuillé par la mort
de deux personnes sur les lignes
d'arrivée des deux
organisateurs dans le bateau achat viré
non loin de la ligne d'arrivée un drame
dont le skipper français n'était pas
encore informé au moment où il est
arrivé Charles coudrelier on le rappelle
à relier Pointe-à-Pitre en six jours
19h47 et 25 secondes c'est hardcore d'où
le titre de Grand Charles en référence
bien sûr un autre grand char le Charles
Charles de Gaulle qui aimait lui aussi
lever les bras en signe de victoire
merci beaucoup Hélène à